[Music]
so far
we have seen different algorithms for
red mapping
the next question that we are going to
ask is whether we can model a particular
dna sequence
and we don't know anything about dna to
predict what it is
and what is its function base on certain
aspects in certain models
for example if we have a new sequence of
dna
what can we do to find out for
information about the sequence
one option is to align it so that we can
do a database search and infer what have
already been known about the similar
sequence
another option is to visualize it so we
can inspect the content of the dna
whether it has a nucleotide composition
that is very different from what we are
supposed to see
does it have certain k-mers which are
existing in higher frequencies than the
others
is there any recurrent pattern that we
observed in the dna and so on
the third option is to model the
particular sequence
modeling refer to the situation where we
can make some hypothesis about the
sequence
for example are there any common
ancestor for the sequence
are there any particular functionality
associated with certain regions of the
sequence
and so on by modeling we are trying to
build a generative model which is a
mathematical model
that will allow us to predict different
functionalities of this dna
given a long sequence of dna different
regions of the dna play a different
function
for example some part of the dna can be
an exon
intron promoter region cpg island and
etc
by building a generative model we will
be able to identify and annotate these
regions given a new piece of unlabeled
dna
of note the generative model must be
able to infer the functionality of
non-identical sequences
and recognize the pattern of known
sequence
once the model is developed we can
classify the non-annotated sequences
based on the annotated regions
these generative models are often
generated by probabilistic modeling
what is it useful to have a
probabilistic model for the biological
sequences
first of all biological data is
oftentimes noisy
data collected from different sources
may give rise to various variations due
to biologically variability
the probabilistic modeling techniques
can be very useful in updating our
previous knowledge that we already have
about the biological sequences
when we are using probabilistic sequence
modeling we are not limited to yes or no
kind of answers
instead it generates answer together
with the level of confidence
one of the probabilistic sequence
modeling that is commonly used is called
the markov models
there are classic markov chains and
there is also extended models for markov
chains which are called hidden markov
models
a classic example of a hidden markov
model is shown here
in this model we have three different
nodes represented in circles
the arrow marks from one node to another
node are called transitions or edges
in this example it is a hidden markov
model to describe the weather of a
particular day
we see that there are different
transitions between sunny weather to
cloudy to raining
for example a transition from sunny to
being cloudy is 0.15 meaning that if a
particular day is sunny the probability
that the next day will be cloudy is 15
the hidden markov models are applied in
different biological sequence analysis
for example hidden markov models have
been used for predicting genes
if we have a new sequence and we want to
identify the genes inside that sequence
we can use hidden markov models to
annotate the regions first
and then identify the location of a gene
hidden markov models can provide very
good genetic models for performing
different dynamic alignment algorithms
for pairwise as well as multiple
sequence alignment
we can also use hidden markov models for
building a profile for a sequence family
base calling determining dna sequencing
errors
prediction of the secondary structure of
protein identifying copy number
variations and many more
in other words hidden markov models are
very important mathematical models that
have been applied in various biological
sequence analysis
here we are going to look at a very
simple example of how we can use markov
chain to model the cpg islands
in the genome the frequency of cg
dinucleotide occurs in low frequency
for example in the human genome the gc
content is about 42 percent
so we should observe g and c with
probability of 21
in frequency for each of them if we
consider this as the expected frequency
of the bases g and c
then the expected frequency that we
should observe the cg dinucleotide is
about 4.41 percent
but in reality we observed only about
one percent
what is the reason that we see this type
of lower frequency of cg dinucleotide
this is because naturally cytosine is
chemically methylated to methyl cytosine
and methylcytosine is easily deaminated
and converted into thymine
the c to t conversion is very naturally
occurring in the dna
as a result the observed frequency of cg
is much lower than the expected
frequency
the methylated cpg residues are often
associated with gene regulation at the
promoter and exon regions
however it is very interesting to note
that there are some regions where this
methylation process
is suppressed particularly in specific
regions near the promoter or the
transcriptional start site of many genes
these regions where methylation process
is suppressed are called cpg islands
in the cpg islands the gc dinucleotide
appears relatively more frequent
compared to the rest of the genome
so identifying the cpg island can be
very useful in identifying different
genes
here is the problem given a short
stretch of genomic sequence
can we decide whether this stretch of
genomic sequence come from a cpg
island or not to solve this problem we
need a model that generates sequences in
which the probability of a symbol
depends on the previous symbol
here is a graph structured model and the
markov chain model for the dna
the graph shows four different nodes a t
g and c
within these nodes there are certain
transitions which denotes the
probability of a particular nucleotide
following another particular nucleotide
by calculating the transition
probability of each node from known cpg
sequence versus non-cpg sequence from
the data set
we can construct the table of transition
probabilities as shown here
for example in the plus or cpg island
data set
the transition probability from a to a
is 0.18
a to c is 0.274 and so forth
it is interesting to note that the
probability of cg is higher in the cpg
model versus the non-cpg model
this is expected as the frequency of
observing the cg dinucleotides in cpg
island is much higher once we have
obtained these models for discrimination
these can be used to compute the log
odds ratio by calculating the log of the
ratio of the probabilities for the plus
model
and the minus model in the table here we
show the beta values which are
represented as bits
we can also plot the data where the
x-axis represents the bits
and we can can see two different areas
the sequences the dark gray represent
the cpg islands
whereas the lighter gray areas
correspond to the other regions
thus we can use two different markov
chain models to identify whether a
particular sequence came from cpg
island or not
you